yesterday jack dorsey and square
announced that they are going to be
changing the name of their company it
will no longer be called square it will
now be called block now this reportedly
has been in the works for more than a
year obviously we saw facebook changed
their name to meta recently so people
were saying are they just copying them
no they have been working on this for
quite a while they feel like the name
square isn't totally descriptive of what
they do today and so the idea is that
jack dorsey along with a number of other
people founded square in 2009 to focus
on in-person payments and they had that
little dongle that little card reader
where you basically plugged it into an
iphone then you could swipe a credit
card the time it made a ton of sense
square it was a square reader but they
obviously now have come and done a ton
more things they have all kinds of
digital banking apps they have all sorts
of other things like after pay which is
a buy now pay later service they even
acquired title the music application as
well so it's not just for in-person
payments anymore this is a company with
a very very large product suite
and so if you go and you actually go
through all the different companies that
are under this new name block it's kind
of like a holding company they have
square itself they have cash app they
have spiral which uh spiral btc which is
their bitcoin focused entity they have
title which is music they have tbd
five four five six six nine seven five
which is focusing on some bitcoin stuff
as well and then they obviously have
after pay on top of it and so we've got
this quote here this is part of the
statement from block it says the name
has many associated meetings for the
company talking about blocks
specifically it says building blocks
neighborhood blocks and they're local
businesses communities coming together
at block parties full of music a
blockchain a section of code and
obstacles to overcome now this is a
trend that we're continuing to see as
companies as they become more and more
mature are saying to themselves maybe
our name doesn't actually fit what we
were intending to do in the beginning
we've seen facebook obviously become
meta we've seen google become alphabet
and now we've seen square become block
do we like the new name or do we feel
like uh it doesn't make a ton of sense i
like it why not i mean square had some
kind of brand value so i thought it was
a little surprising that they did this
and the statement was a little
interesting like you know block stands
for building blocks at your community
and i was like okay well i think we know
where you're going with this uh but yeah
i think it's cool i mean obviously
the feeling that this uh gives off is
that square is gonna focus a lot more on
the blockchain side of things and now
that jack has more time and is going to
be spending more time on square or block
specifically
i think that's a good sign
john i like it i like what jack's doing
he left twitter he is now going full
time into square block
all these companies obviously it does
kind of lead to you're focusing on
blockchain bitcoin all the things that
he's been working on square has they
bought what they bought
50 million
bitcoin in october 170 million earlier
this year worth of bitcoin so they
obviously hold a lot
yeah i mean like it doesn't really
matter does it like square is still
square it's similar to what facebook is
doing they're they have the same company
trajectory and what they're focusing on
in their company but they're just making
that known through their actual holding
company's name i don't think it really
matters in the grand scheme of things
for square or any of the other companies
that are subsidiaries of it can i uh
tell you if i put my conspiracy theory
hat on a wild idea that i had this
morning i have no inside knowledge of
this whatsoever i know nothing about uh
what i'm about to say right
how crazy would it be david marcus who
was running facebook financial f2
he just left
how crazy would it be if he went to what
is now block and somehow uh was running
one of these divisions or was an
executive at the company i wouldn't be
surprised former president of paypal ran
facebook financial we know that he's
very into bitcoin he's been on uh the
podcast before and talked about it uh
believes a lot in this technology
looks like a free agent looks like
jack's going all in on bitcoin uh some
of these technologies would be pretty
cool to see that happen right are they
friends
i'm sure they know each other yeah right
you know and and look uh david uh one
obviously is uh incredibly intelligent
hardworking very successful in a number
of different roles now uh but he is a
payments expert right now put in their
quiz because i don't know if anyone's
actually an expert in anything but uh he
was at paypal as the president he then
came over to facebook was doing
messenger then was doing facebook
financial uh was very heavily involved
in uh the launch of libra diem the
wallet i mean he's been thinking about
these technologies he's an early
investor in bitcoin if you read the book
digital gold he's right there in the
book in terms of the early days of
bitcoin uh um understanding the value of
it uh and now you see square continue to
go further and further into the space
like wouldn't be surprised me to see him
potentially uh at least have a
conversation about joining is novi his
new company that he's going that was the
part of facebook that was facebook's
financial yeah so the idea would be you
know is there something there to be done
in terms of david uh going full on into
bitcoin like that could be interesting
i think so i mean i don't know i i i
wasn't super shocked that he left to be
honest because it looked like facebook
wasn't making a ton of progress they
already rolled out some products that
obviously didn't go as well as they
assumed that they would or expected that
they would uh so it wasn't really
surprising to see him leave he's
obviously an intelligent guy that's done
a lot of good things in the payment
structure uh kind of business so if he
can feel if he feels like he can make a
greater impact at an organization like
block or in one of their one of their
kind of silos of uh you know bitcoin or
blockchain payment services then it
wouldn't be surprising at all to see him
go there
i think that's right